- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is do what you love.
Over to you, Future.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I'm most comfortable
when I'm in the studio,
and nothing else matters but the music.
You got this love for it,
for something that you think about.
You sleep and you dream and you wake up
and you breathe it and
you want to live it.
There's so many options,
there's many ways to blow up,
there's many ways to be known
and to get success and to be successful.
It's just about picking
that way that feeds you.
- So here's the path for
so many successful people.
You get an interest in something,
you want to try something, so you try it.
You suck at it, but you really enjoyed it
so you come back and you do it again.
And you try to get better and you improve.
You come back, you suck a little bit less
but you're still really bad,
but you love it so much
you have to keep doing it.
Even though it doesn't make sense,
even though you're not
seeing any kind of return,
you just love doing it.
Even though people are
telling you that you're crazy,
even though your parents
or your friends are saying
what the heck are you doing,
this doesn't make any sense
in the world.
You have to keep doing it
because you love the process.
And slowly here's what happens.
You get a little bit better,
you get a little bit better,
you work harder, you
get a little bit better.
Now suddenly, you're average.
You're just average, but
you're still spending time,
you're still spending effort,
you're still hustling
to try to get better.
You still have the
people around you saying
that you're crazy, that
you're never going to make it,
that the numbers are against you.
Why don't you do the smart,
safe, practical thing to do
and go on that other route
instead of doing this thing?
'Cause now you're just average.
I got to keep doing it, I love it.
So you do more, you practice harder,
you hustle, you hustle, you
hustle, you grind it more.
Now you're good, now you're good.
Now maybe you've made even a
little bit of money off of it,
whatever this hobby,
passion thing is of yours.
And you still got the people saying
you're never going to make it.
You're just making a little bit of money,
how are you ever going to
turn that thing into a career?
It's never going to happen for you.
There's no way.
Look at all these
massively talented people
who are ahead of you.
You think you're going to
compete with those guys?
You think you're going
to win in that game?
It's not going to happen.
But you love it, you love the process.
And so you work harder, and
you continue to practice
and you get good and you
get better, and you improve,
and you improve, and you improve.
And now you're above average,
you're better than good.
You're starting to get great.
Maybe you're starting to
almost make a full time income
from this thing.
And people will still look at you,
you're still doing this?
Why are you still doing this?
You spent these years
working on this thing,
you should've been way
ahead in this other career
and now you're paying your bills but
you're never going to be that great thing.
What do you do?
You love the process.
You keep working at it,
you keep working at it,
and then you get great,
and then you get amazing,
and then you win.
That's the success story for
almost every successful person
that we've profiled.
They sucked at the start.
But they loved the process
and they kept going
and they improved and they got better.
That's how you win.
If you feel this thing inside you
where you love the process
of doing something.
Don't be so concerned with
how it's going to work out.
'Cause quite often the idea
that you have in your head,
is not how it's going to work out.
The end result is not what you're chasing,
the process is what you're chasing.
When I started this YouTube channel,
it wasn't to become YouTube famous.
That wasn't part of my goal.
I didn't even know how I
was going to ever make money
off of this, making money
helping entrepreneurs.
The first thing I did was
three people showed up
to a free event.
How are you ever going to
make money off of something
if you can't get more than three people
to come to a free event?
And the world opened up to me in a way
that I never thought possible.
I never thought I'd get a book deal
with Penguin Random House.
I never thought I'd be asked to join
boards of directors in different companies
and get paid to do it.
I never thought I'd work with big brands
who would then hire me out to
work with them on projects.
I never thought these things would happen
and it wasn't even on my radar as
in my business model or my plan.
What I wanted to do was
create amazing content
to help entrepreneurs.
Helping entrepreneurs feeds my soul
and I had to find a way to do it
even if I never made any money.
And it's because I have
passion and determination
that I ended up making money.
That's how it works.
So find the thing that you love doing,
that you have insane passion towards
and figure out a way to do
that as much as possible,
practice as hard as you can
even if you absolutely suck at the start
because that's the thing that's
going to make you come alive.
That's the thing where you're
going to deliver insane value
to the world at some point
when you get really good at it.
And the only way to get
there is to practice,
and practice, and practice,
and practice, and practice
and stop listening to
the people around you
who say that you'll never
make it and you can't do it.
So the question today
guys is what do you love?
Leave it in the comments,
I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to James Mitchell.
James, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really means a lot to me man.
I appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another Shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Statistics said if I did that
and I stopped going to school
and that's all I did was hang in the hood,
then I wasn't going to be here today.
So that's why I still
hang with the same people
that I was with back in the hood
and I changed my mentality.
I don't think the same way
I was when I was there.
I opened my mind up, I thought broader,
I thought outside of my horizons.
And like you got to think outside the box
because that's the only way
you're going to get out.
When you're trapped in the trap,
you're really mentally
trapped in the trap.
And it's me like man, I
want to make sure my people
just know that that's just
not the end of your life.
Like if somebody tells
you, these statistics,
this is not you.
You're going to fight statistics
and go to the next level.
Like statistics said I
wouldn't even be here
talking to you right now,
if I were to listen to them
and tell them how my life
how my life would've been.
They say one out of ten people,
they're going to be like this
or nine out of ten Black
males, if they do this,
live this way, they're going to do this.
You know what I'm saying?
There's no way around it.
They're going to tell you
there's no way around it.
So if you're in the hood right now,
you're standing on the block everyday.
The police just riding by that old lady
that's looking at you, just
calling the police on you.
The people who're riding
by just looking at you
like they ain't nothing.
Your parents saying it,
they think you ain't
never going to be nothing,
they think you're going to be like that
for the rest of your life.
Who is the person to tell you
that you're going to be
standing on this block
all your life?
It's supposed to be a point in your life
where you only be here for, you
give yourself a year or two.
You're from here, it don't do no good
for you to be here all your life.
And you spending the
majority of your life,
22 hours out of your day, trying to prove
you're the hardest in the hood.
You come from this, you were born in this.
When you came home from the hospital,
you went to the hood.
You know what I'm saying?
So you don't live your whole life this way
for all your life.
You deserve to live in a
different neighborhood,
to better yourself for three, four years
out of your whole life, when
you've been living this way
probably, some dudes been living that way
for 20 years, 23 years.
Been in the hood since they
came home from the hospital
and they're still trying
to prove to the hood
how hard they are and
they end up not making it.
Because they didn't prove to themselves,
you got to prove to
yourself that you want more
than what the hood has to offer.
At the end of the day, from my first song,
when I first made it my head.
I knew what I could do,
you know what I'm saying?
I know the type of artist that I am,
I know the caliber of
music that I can come with
and I know I can continue to do it.
I was born to make music
and when you got a gift for something,
you just got to know how to utilize it.
And when I found a way to utilize it
and just make the most of my opportunity,
I know I have to be...
I'm an artist, I have
to stay in the studio
and create all the time,
you know what I'm saying?
If I was to lay off and
not go to the studio,
then all those he say, she says,
it might've came true,
but I knew the work that I was putting in.
The key to success is like,
when you haven't been successful
you don't know what's the key to success,
how to be successful.
You know the right
moves that you're making
and every move that you're
making and you're striving
and you're just achieving certain things
that you made goals for yourself.
You set goals and you achieve goals
but at the end of the day,
you still set your standards high.
For when you reach a certain plateau
and then you know man, I got
to go to that next level,
you know what I'm saying?
When you want to be successful, like,
success is different for other people,
you know what I mean?
Success for me is just making music
and that's being successful is just
winning a Grammy,
you know what I mean?